first on CTM we paid a visit to the
six-year-old
baseball coach known as coach Drake
adorable video show Drake Livingstone
giving pep talks to players and arguing
with an umpire at Kalamazoo Michigan
growler games growlers it's his first
year as an assistant pitching coach in
this summer college league and he's
quickly become a fan favorite CBS this
morning correspondent vladimir duthiers
is here we Drake story Vlad what did you
learn about this pint-sized terror I'm
going to tell you Tony we learned coach
Drake's dad works for the growlers
organization the team says they brought
Drake on board to make the game's more
exciting his infectious passion for the
game is on full display in those videos
and even though Drake is actually pretty
camera shy let me tell you he means
business
six-year-old Drake Livingston has become
an internet sensation
I'm the pitching coach with his look of
determination and trademark marched to
the mound
coach drinks gonna come out just talk a
little bit stretchy here trying to
figure out how they're gonna keep up
this defense that they've had first
people to know there's a joke was going
on quick wave of the cap but it wasn't
long before coach Drake became a staple
at growlers game he's a serious kid he
wants players to play the game the right
way he wants the guys first and foremost
to have fun it's for the fans that are
there to enjoy the show
[Applause]
he'll dance on the dugout and take
pictures with fans but like most
six-year-olds he's also known to throw
the occasional tantrum out comes coach
strake he did not like the last ball
because I'm just signature move oh oh he
might get tossed and he's gone oh no you
just say I'll be right back was that the
hall be right back finger Drake will
argue with umpires over bad calls with
the passion of a major league manager oh
here comes more bats throwing bats this
is the biggest outburst we have seen
from coach Drake in a long time and even
dumping buckets of balls on the field he
holds the record for most ejections in
the Northwoods League this is the most
anger I've ever seen out of a
six-year-old spiking his hat on home
plate the ultimate sign of disrespect
Jake is a very passionate kid and there
has been a few instances where his
passion is overwhelming but Drake's that
Cody says it's all in good fun
and for the love of the game he's really
been great with the guys and the team
atmosphere of it has really been
important for him being around the guys
just doing anything he can for the team
has been just a godson I don't want to
play baseball forever he brings a joy to
the to the clubhouse and our fan base he
gives more than he takes and if you can
do that in life what we're all being a
better place it is worth noting the team
would not tell us exactly how much of
coach Drake's performance is an act but
Drake's dad did say they've watched
baseball games together since he was a
baby so he picked up some moves along
the way the team's GM says the next step
is getting coach Drake to meet the real
dream now he's here his favorite song of
course is Kiki do you love me right and
that's his favorite song the hunch will
determined Walker berry he says he's
watch a lot of Lou Pinella videos
but now ya put my finger on he is paid
in gummy bears and high-fives but one
thing to the growlers gummy bears don't
pay for college tuition and here's the
thing he can act all day long but if I
say clean up your room better not give
me that the ultimate side of this love
you you're very cute alright don't give
your parents a hard time I'm glad thank
you very much